[Applause]
good morning everybody I'm so excited to
announce the nominations in eight
categories for the 53rd annual Academy
of Country Music Award so let's get
started up for new female vocalist of
the year Lauren Alaina Danielle Bradbery
karlie Pierce and Raylan
and the nominees for new male vocalist
of the year Kane Brown Luke combs Devon
Dawson
Russell Dickerson and Brett young and
the nominees for new vocal duo or group
of the year high valley Lenco low cash
Midland and runaway June and up for
album of the year
breaker a Little Big Town California
sunrise John party from a room volume
one Chris Stapleton happy endings
Old Dominion and life changes Thomas
Rhett and the nominees for a single
record of the year better man Little Big
Town but it like a backroad Sam hunt
broken halos Chris Stapleton drinkin
problem Midland and I'll name the dogs
Blake Shelton and for video of the year
black Dierks Bentley it ain't my fault
brothers Osborne legends Kelsea
Ballerini marry me Thomas Rhett and we
should be friends Miranda Lambert and up
for songwriter of the year Rhett Akins
Ashley Gourley Hilary Lindsey Shayne
mcanally
and Josh Osborne and the nominees for
vocal event of the year
craving you Thomas Rhett featuring Maren
Morris deer hate Maren Morris featuring
Vince Gill funny how time slips away
Glen Campbell and Willie Nelson the
fighter Keith Urban featuring Carrie
Underwood and what ifs Kane Brown
featuring Lauren Alaina so a huge
congratulations to all the nominees and
the ACM Awards air on CBS April the 15th
do not miss that
and we of course are going to have
complete covers again congratulations
[Music]